[Music]
and if you need it for the
oh wow
this is a different daniel green than
we're used to this is daniel b
green oh yeah the the yeah
what is it is it like buttercup
yeah actually it's daniel buttercup
green i'm surprised you got that right
no one ever guesses that
i'm a pretty good guesser
i figured we could just start talking
about breach of peace
bop as as the as the young kids are
calling it do i get a point for every
question i answer right each point is
like 1 100th of a penny
god damn it all right well all right
there's gonna be a long interview
because i need to at least
at least to make a dollar so i know well
uh congrats breach of peace
thank you yeah hold that hold that
please
breach of peace is blowing up right now
i just checked like right before we
recorded it's 143 in the kindle store
currently i know it's like 52. it's it's
it's doing amazing congrats
how does it feel that's
my question um
i i haven't processed it if i'm being
honest like i i got told i was number
one in military fantasy and i was like
oh that's a great subgenre to be number
one in
um and i was told i was number one in
horror fantasy and i was like i don't
think i'm
writing a horror book but cool i didn't
categorize it at that
um and then i was told it was number one
in epic fantasy and i was like
no way and i started watching it rise
and throughout the whole first day i
kept rising and rising and rising i
couldn't sleep that night because i just
kept checking like i don't want to miss
it being in his top spot and around like
1am it started going back down i was all
right cool i can still
rest yeah it's time to actually like not
watch
because if i watch it go down all the
way i'll start getting sad so i stopped
watching at that point
time to sleep but it felt very weird uh
i
genuinely like people have been laughing
at me for saying this i didn't think i'd
sell that many copies i didn't think
that many people would be interested in
my book because i thought you know
people
watch me for reviews and watching the
review guy try to write a book it's like
that's not gonna be good
i i laughed at you for saying that too i
watched your stream and i was just like
ha
but uh like you're about to say you
laughed at me for like writing a book i
remember like i laughed at you for
writing a book no um but yeah it's
been unbelievable uh i of course there's
the imposter syndrome kicking in like
really hard but you've gotta ignore that
as somebody who's
who's you know privileged enough to have
read it multiple times i uh
i have to say that it's it's awesome
it's really awesome man
everyone they have a lot of uh good
coming to them
on march 30th just saying well you you
read early i don't
get you the final draft you read it
before the pros got like
touched up and made better and
everything so hopefully it's better now
i'd hate for you to get the final
version to be like nah
the unedited was where it's at like
that's
no yeah i've read um yeah you sent me
the the new version and i read that
it's great on all i mean the the story
was you know consistent through
through everything and it's just yeah
the pros is terrific
you know thank you i still say pros are
so that's where i'm at pros why
i i've been meaning to fight you about
that for a long time i'm sure a lot of
people just know
it sounds better in my mind and i can't
make the switch
my brain like refuses to so i keep
saying in videos and every time the
people come in like
what are you doing you got to stand for
what you believe in totally
was there anything that surprised you
about writing
breach of peace also what is your
writing process
so the surprising thing everyone told me
that writing is not the hardest part and
in my cocky brain i was like that's not
true writing's the hardest part
uh no self-publishing is the hardest
part buy a lot
by a huge margin uh writing was
difficult don't get me wrong i hit
writer's block i had all this stuff i
mean it took me months to write 140
pages
it's not easy to you know write but
self-publishing
it's not a herculean task in the sense
that anything is specifically very hard
to do
you just have to do a million things you
have to
find distribute the distributor you want
you have to upload you have to edit you
have to edit again you have to edit
again you have to edit again you have to
edit again
i could repeat that for an hour um you
need to
you know if some figure out okay the
distributor i chose is going to handle
these channels but i need to
individually upload and handle all these
other channels it's not going to handle
so that people can get it in these other
means if you want to do an audio book
whole other set of tasks and then once
you've
finished all this you're going to find
big mistakes in your book and you need
to re-upload your book everywhere
repeatedly it's it's it's a death by a
thousand cuts situation and you just
need to keep moving forward
it's really amazing how hard
self-publishing is and but at the end of
it you get to keep
that much more of the money you make so
worth it
yeah that's i i'd say that's worth it
that's pretty awesome
i can't imagine how much work is going
into that plus you're
still keeping up with your youtube
schedule the whole time
yeah um well there's a reason there's
been a lot less book reviews for me
recently it's because
the amount i've been able to read is way
down because i'm just focusing on
getting my book out fortunately bad
movies exist and i've started filling my
schedule with watching and reviewing bad
movies
so that's been great and people had a
wonderful time with that
that's perfect i'm curious about um how
you found your cover artist
so i reached out to a couple different
artists i'm kind of friendly with to
figure out where they got their covers
done and they sent me artists they'd
work with
and i got sent felix ortiz
and i started looking through his work
and just immediately was
blown away i mean the guys work with
color and
just vibrant textures the way you mean
i don't deserve a cover this nice uh i i
don't i got
my favorite part of my book is now the
cover that in michael kramer k writing
narrating it's not my book
which i don't know what that says about
me uh and
i would say the turnaround with him was
also unbelievable
i think it was a total from two months
when i first contacted him to when he
sent me the final version
uh he's fantastic i can't recommend him
enough someone's out there looking for a
book cover felix ortiz is
i mean there's a reason he won the
stabbie for best cover artist right now
he's
brilliant loved working with him i feel
like people are curious about
where you stand on panting versus
outlining so
i tried both i approached this book
in two different directions or this
novella uh and
the first time i tried to just write it
i just tried to like burn through the
whole thing
and get it done and that kind of ended
up very messy but it was my first draft
i then kind of went back through
and took all the major plot elements
that i knew i needed to hit
cut out a lot of the fat and then
decided what i needed to add in to make
these plot elements work better
it's actually kind of how i approach the
world building too i just was like
here's the world i want
okay now let's go through top to bottom
repeatedly and start kind of fully
painting out and texturizing what i want
this to be all the way through
um it was a long process and i'm still
developing the world honestly like every
author who's currently writing
their series is still developing their
world you don't finish um
and it's it's the most fun part honestly
i think writing is fun
and that's why i'm really looking
forward to getting deeper into book two
i have book two like 50
done and yeah and so it's it's really
great to
getting back into it after i handle
getting this in people's hands
um my biggest advice for people who are
trying to figure out their prancer
or plotter is to just try and get
through it in one go
and if you haven't if that didn't feel
right to you you can still
use what you tried as an outline of
sorts and then be an outliner from there
absolutely that's really that's
interesting what you say about your
world building do you keep like a list
of like
information like country all that kind
of stuff
uh yes i kind of have a
document that is the most grotesque
unorganized thing ever
i by the way yeah i also use campfire
which has been uh
they're a sponsor i don't wanna bring up
a sponsor on a channel but
they are genuinely an amazing tool and
uh they're using them to help organize
my world has been a game changer because
you know i do have this giant ugly
document and then i've been slowly
piecing that into campfire over time
and that really helps honestly some of
their tools are more useful than others
but the most useful for me has been
keeping all the factions organized that
way
because if you have an idea for a
kingdom over here and you come back to
that kingdom three months later
and you're trying to scroll through your
notes to figure out what you wanted to
do
it's just time consuming um so having
something like that
it sounds like i'm trying to make money
here but it's just it's real i mean
that's it's a nice tool to have
campfire sponsor me now i
do oh quick question and this is
something
i have to ask this because my wife
wanted to know she if
you're moving again because you're being
chased by the law
or if you committed any kind of crime
like if are the feds catching up to you
that's what we want to know
i've had issues with people finding my
address before and things like that
that's actually a motivator for me
moving before fortunately this time me
moving
is actually just i want to move i like
my apartment my apartment's really nice
but i'm moving into a more permanent
location
and forcing myself to put down roots i
have moved
more than five times in the last five
years and i just am like okay
you are not a functioning adult you
don't have roots anywhere
do it so i'm making myself uh move again
so that i can be a
real human being who's tied to a
location so basically the feds have not
caught up to you that's what you're
saying no i actually
i'm i'm the zodiac killer so you know
hold on can you say that one more time
no
i'm curious about how you feel about
like inserting like political or like
moral questions
in your book like do you feel like it's
a conscious thing that you tried to
do or is it more focusing on the story
whatever
enters enters i will never tell someone
they are right or wrong
for putting politics in their book or
not you're welcome to do either way
you're welcome to
you know inject as much as you'd like or
be completely you know apolitical in
your writing
so i'm i'm not going to answer that
question a way where it's like yes or no
but for me personally there's a lot of
politics in my book
uh very orwellian i'm heavily pulling
from orwell
and i kind of wanted to create like what
if
the religious cult took over what if the
whole world is run by
a god and there's not really free will
anymore because if god is sitting there
going do this
you're going to go do that is that right
is that wrong
that's kind of what i'm exploring so
that's the big thesis
pretty much of my politics my religion
is
you are following the main characters
are part of this empire they are
religious zealots
and it's kind of an exploration of what
is the mindset of good people
who are in a situation like that can you
be a good person in a situation like
that
um and so i've been doing a lot of
reading into you know
the average everyday life of someone who
is in nazi germany you know if you're
just walking in the street but you're in
nazi germany
what's your life like um same thing with
uh manifest destiny which is one of the
most evil concepts in history the idea
that it's your religious right to own
this land that you can push whoever
out of the way that's something these
people believe in and some of the most
horrific instances in history have all
come from stuff like that it's been a
very depressing series of research
uh but it's also been fascinating to see
how simple ideas
can be put in people's minds and then
those people will go do awful awful
awful things
yeah i mean for 140 160 pages it really
packs a lot of
interesting thought-provoking ideas i
mean it it leaves a lot to think about
and i i really like how it doesn't it
doesn't like bring some kind of simple
resolution it really
just presents a lot of interesting
questions yeah and in a lot of
situations like this where you have an
orwellian type government and you have a
military that crosses lines into
civilian matters
what ends up happening with the police
that's actually something that's been a
problem in history where
if the military's jurisdiction is
all-consuming what happens when the
police and the military start
conflicting
are the police truly representatives of
the people or are they another
arm of the government um and it's it's
another idea i like to look into because
i've found
you know people who typically join up
with law enforcement you know this is a
very
controversial thing right now for many
reasons but they either are very abusive
of their power or they're very genuinely
trying to help their communities there's
kind of
two sides of you know people who want to
get into that line of work
and so i i and not in this book quite as
much but in the next book especially
there's gonna be a lot of
you know who are the kind of people who
try and put themselves in these shoes
who want to be in an authoritative
position
right it's really fascinating because
the inspectors are like
elevated to god-like status um and it's
like what
what are the consequences when like a
police force is treated that way
yeah oh god i mean that's there's so
much you know
raising of people up in cults and
religion there's so much of this person
is above you now
because of what they've been assigned
and i've for my whole life found that to
be a very toxic and awful idea no one
person is better than anyone else i mean
this is coming from someone who's
you know i'm an agnostic i'm not someone
who i believe we're all just monkeys who
figured stuff out
and so i don't really believe one person
is ever truly better than another
so i from my perspective going into that
idea of elevating an individual
in a cult-like sense uh was really
interesting because as someone who's
never really had religion much in their
life i've always i've always been
fascinated by it i mean i've studied it
a lot i
took a lot of classes on religion in
college knox is related to my major
it's because it's it's it's the most
shaping force in our history like
religion has directed human history
more than pretty much any other factor
you can't really
debate that it's just from the crusades
to even world war ii religion played a
role
well you did a a really fantastic job
presenting these ideas and it's
it's definitely a lot to to think about
i'm wondering um
like you talked about george or orwell
but wondering if there were
other like conscious influences you are
thinking of
like either fantasy writers or outside
the fantasy fantasy genre or
probably surprising some people is not
much from jordan or sanderson
um because i i love those guys they're
two of my favorites
i was surprised i was definitely
surprised when i read it it's just i i
don't find their writing style to be
um what makes me love them i think they
have really good solid writing style but
it's not
there's no flair to it that makes the
the factor that pulls me into their
stories which just makes the rest of
their stories all the more impressive
but
for me i think i mean i had a tweet a
while ago that got retweeted by stephen
king that was talking about how much i
love the way he writes he kind of has
this blue
yeah he has this uh blue collar
beauty to him where he's able to use
very simple writing
to explain and delve into complex ideas
and emotions especially emotions like
fear
and revulsion and i wanted to really
pull from that
i also definitely of course respect and
love abercrombie's writing style i'll
never
claim to write as good as these people
but it's what i tried to
have influenced me it's what i was
trying to go on my way to pull from
i i hope i did it to a somewhat decent
effect is all i can really say um
i found my prose upon like going back
and reading the book the best i can
because you can never really read your
own book if that makes sense but
i found my prose to be a bit basic to be
a bit bland
um and it's something i'm working on but
i hope there's enough flavor there so
it's not just
you know flavorless for people no i
think there there is a lot of flavor and
i really see
like the stephen king influence
definitely especially in certain
scenes that are very dark twisted not
gonna get into spoilers or anything but
just very um
it's very immersive and the details are
uh
sort of like uh how stephen king is very
focused on just like the
there's some disturbing imagery in there
i was really shocked to see that
that influence there so i people are
calling this grim dark and i don't agree
because i don't think stephen king is
grimdark but he's willing to go into
graphic detail
and what i studied most when i was going
through his writing specifically for
this
was how he forces your gaze how he
makes you as the reader look at
something and then he can use that a
small detail like a bodily fluid or
something really revolting
to then your mind fills in the rest like
you will expand the rest of the the
situation simply this this book opens to
the crime scene and so there's
really graphic detail about what was
done to these people
and there's one scene in the bedroom
where i probably could have cut that
whole scene
but it was an exercise for me of just
trying to actually paint a picture of
something gruesome
and you know talking about someone being
torn apart
and it's it's about okay how can i
really affect a reader's emotion and i
ended up kind of liking what i
accomplished so i kept it in there
because i thought it was a
emotional enough scene in terms of
showing how these characters can handle
uh watching this happen to an adult
where they aren't that revolted where
they watch it before happen to a child
and that really turns like
they are revolted by it i wanted to keep
it in because i think it does a good
amount of character work for the
inspectors
um and it also uh was a nice exercise i
think turned out well i mean this book
is an exercise for me in a lot of ways
it's my first ever thing i really wrote
all the way through that's a novella
and i i think it there's there's gonna
be sequences i think if you pay close
attention you can go oh daniel is
working on
this in that sequence right yeah and i
i could also tell that too having read
the first draft and then the final draft
like
those those visceral elements especially
like you were talking about
in in the bedroom that was expanded upon
and it's interesting how you don't
classify it as grim dark and i don't
think it's grim dark either because i
feel like there's a kind of like
tone sort of like how you talk about how
stephen king is in grim dark i feel like
he's not grim dark because
overall there's like a like a
hopefulness
in stephen king's books that's not it's
he's not a pessimistic
pessimistic writer and i don't think you
are either no i i think
stephen king and i i've tried to pull
from this as well he has a belief in
people
um people will fight for good there's
never a everyone's bad
there's never and i think one of the
core elements to grim dark is a belief
that people are selfish
and they're self-serving and that's what
really qualifies grimdark for me
is that every character you come across
at least almost every single one
especially ones in power are evil in
some way or they're gray
uh very rarely in a grim dark story to
someone who is truly good take the
spotlight
if they are they corrupt their get
corrupted um i
i don't believe that about people
personally i think grimdark's actually
less realistic i think history and
psychology has shown us that most people
at least in their own twisted minds if
they're doing evil things are trying to
be good do good
the ted bundys the jeffrey dahmers those
are extreme outliers
um in in reality in my opinion no yeah
i agree absolutely obviously there's
also the arthur conan doyle
influences which i could tell you were
having
a lot of fun in the procedural stuff
which was just very entertaining to read
i don't want to pull from his writing
style because i genuinely don't love
certain cornell's writing style but
his specific writing of mystery is the
greatest that there's ever been and i
will fight it about that anyone any day
um and so there is a character in this
who is my twisted version of sherlock
where he's he's an ass he's not the main
character
he's kind of a secondary character i
would say to cut to [ __ ]
i say my own character's name wrong
isn't that great
kate reading says it right if you listen
to the audiobook she says it right um
and i wanted to show what i thought
a real sherlock would be like if they
were put in a situation where they were
working in a religious cult like this
if they were someone who somewhat
believed in it and
also didn't i think people who have that
level of intelligence they are innately
very sad
and they are also very innately
disrespectful of boundaries
because the people i've found in my life
who are i have a couple of friends who
are far more intelligent than me they
are
very smart and i have found that they
are the kind of people in conversation
will just say a thing they know is true
and it's very cutting it's very beyond
what your normal person would say
but you you know it's honest and it's
real so you're like yeah
right there
i hear you and i really love getting to
see that character's point of view
because you you can see that you know
he's not trying to be an
[ __ ] it's just the way his brain is
wired
yeah and i also didn't want to do the
disrespectful thing of making him like
some shallow representation of a
disability or something that's not
he's not disabled he's just not socially
functioning
um as someone who did struggle a lot you
know socially getting to learn how to do
that because homeschool for a long time
that was thrown into public schools i
had to learn how to socialize at a later
age
i know what that feeling is like i
wasn't disabled socially in any way i
was just
not i didn't know how and i kind of just
brought that into that character that
same feeling i had in eighth grade
i put into this grown ass man because it
just kind of felt right
right um there's also a lot of comedy i
noticed
and uh you know reading it again i was
like there's actually a lot of funny
moments i especially love the
officer shit's uh little uh internal
dialogue that
uh chapman has do you feel like do you
consciously think
like uh i need to put a joke in here or
lighten things up or is it just how your
brain works
i 100 believe writing
humor is the most difficult thing to do
great it's okay you can do it well
easily enough
but doing great humor is not something
i'll even strive to do like
i think there are three authors i can
think of who every single joke they
write
lands um that's it neil gaiman terry
pratchett
and no i'm just going to give it to
those two
100 of people 100 of jokes they write
knocking it out of the park
beyond that i think writing humor for me
it just came down to does it feel right
for the character to say this in that
moment
yes put it in and i don't think i ever
did anything hilarious i just did small
moments because it's all i could really
manage and i didn't want to push beyond
that there was a line
where i had two inspectors entering a
market
and one inspector looks at another and
goes go left and one goes right
and then he walks left it was like ha ha
he was making a dumb joke
and everyone i showed that line to went
take it out that's bad
and i was like all right fine and that
was where i realized okay don't put just
jokes in put in character based moments
where it makes sense for some kind of
humor to happen
yeah yeah and there's some some great
moments like that and uh thank you
yeah i i really love uh the characters
um i'm i'm curious if you if you plot
out your character development or if you
just
you know feel it as you go along so
helen's the only character where i
really felt good need to have
development happen in the story everyone
else is pretty set in their ways
that's actually something i think is a
problem sometimes where
people force development to happen to a
character that doesn't make sense
um if someone's a 30 40 year old man and
they're going about their day
and they're going like yeah even if
extreme circumstances happen to them
it doesn't always make sense to them to
change throughout that day
only the main character i felt really
was someone who was going to be broken
apart
and be different by the end of this
story um
so i think some people and i'm ready to
have the criticism to say this is kind
of more one-dimensional characters in
some aspects and i think they're right
but that's also what i was going for
everyone but the main character is
pretty much going to stay who they are
because to me it just i didn't want to
force something that felt unnecessary
especially when i'm so page condensed
and i need to just get to the ending
without any fat
yeah absolutely i mean you're not
writing a you know 400 page book
i'm curious about and i don't know how
much you can tell us
or how much you know about the lawful
times trilogy
and what we could maybe expect from
sequels
i think i'll definitely do better the
second book and that's not to say this
first book
is bad i just it's very amazing
sorry it's very surprising how much you
can tell
your faults just after having one
completed work once you really are
saying okay this is my book it's done
it's been edited i'm proud of it i like
it and then you read it through
you'll still like it you'll still be
proud of it and so far the reviews i've
gotten have been positive
but you will be your biggest critic and
you'll see where you fell short so i
think i hope for the next book i'll
improve on those aspects um in terms of
the story
i think the best thing that i can say is
this mystery is going to hopefully
impress people
you are not getting all the answers in
book one and
what is going to be shown by the end of
book three
will i hope entice people to pick up the
actual main
novel i'm working on as well uh because
you've
if you finish this book you've actually
met the main character of that novel um
and that's something that i think people
will be surprised at who that turns out
to be
that's that's really exciting i'm very
very excited to read those
to wrap up the the our section on
writing here my questions about writing
is do you have any
tips for people starting out on their
first
work on their first book get an editor
even if you don't plan on uh releasing
it even if you
just are writing something for yourself
keep putting it in the hands of someone
who professionally will go through it
and tell you
objectively what is wrong who's not your
friend who's not trying to be nice to
you
will be an amazing uh directional
push it'll show you where you need to
work so going online and you can find
people who will do this for
less than 100 bucks they'll go through a
novella and do it for less than 100
bucks
i think is a truly worthwhile endeavor
i certainly really knew where i needed
to work on my pros
after i got the first couple rounds of
editing done
so i'm curious about how you've been
able to
balance writing your books uh
and you know doing your work on youtube
so i recently pulled back from doing
seven days a week videos to five days a
week videos
and if i hadn't done that pullback i
would not have been able to write this
book period
uh also i am a workaholic i am a
self-confessed
in therapy for it literally a workaholic
who is trying to
not do this as much uh so that is a big
factor into how i was able to do this
was you know i like to work 12 hours a
day
or 16 and i will wake up and go to bed
and just do it again
my friends have been great in getting me
to try and stop this
so that's been helping me pull back but
my genuine advice to people who look at
what i am doing
and say how can i do all of that is uh
don't
it's not mentally healthy it's not
sustainable it's why i've had to
skip days and just tweet out hey i need
a mental health day because i'm just so
burnt i can't do anything but just lay
in bed and try and recover
um so there's there is things happening
behind the scenes that are not healthy
that's all i can say but i'm getting
better um
but for people who are running smaller
booktube channels and want to put
something out
one start writing and get your audience
involved put that pressure on yourself
to tell your audience what you're doing
so that you will then keep going i know
that sounds like a lot of pressure
but that will keep you writing um and on
top of that if you want a booktube
channel that's gonna make it right now
your personality has to be genuine
that's all i have to say like you i
don't care if you're shy i don't care if
you're outgoing i don't care if you're
funny or serious
don't force yourself to be something
else just really put yourself at the
face of the channel and be genuine
don't lie about your opinions to try and
please people
even if you lose subs for doing it if
you say you hate lord of the rings and
lose 50 subs one day that's
fine because another 50 saw what you
said and they respected your honest
opinion they're going to trust you and
come back to you
um that's that's real that's that's the
biggest advice i can give you
that's great i think people are are so
drawn to your channel because you
you are willing to take those unpopular
opinions sometimes
um six of crows is bad
well i think the the tip about um if
you're writing and doing youtube i think
i think that's
good advice although for myself it is
scary to just
say like hey i'm writing and it's going
to come out at a certain point you know
to set those expectations i've been
afraid to say stuff like that because
it's like
well i what my experience is people were
patient because it was over two years
ago that i said i was gonna start
working on a book
and i never was getting like angry
comments saying like go faster
most people surprisingly just don't care
most people are like that's whatever
that's fine
occasionally you'll get a ping that's
like hey are you still working on that
and if so
great um it's really going to be the
pressure's internal it's going to be you
yelling at yourself
and that's sometimes what people need so
that's that's why i say it
to be honest though your audience is
going to pressure you much unless you're
bringing it up
all the time i think your audience is
just uh has been awesome especially
around the release of this book i mean
everyone's
psyched and very positive and uh i just
think you've built like an amazing
community with your
your channel i i love them i mean
there's i i used to think it was so
annoying what i'd see youtubers be like
i love my audience they mean the world
to me thank you i'm like you don't know
your audience but you kind of
get to know your audience it eventually
forms
kind of into this being that you're like
i know
my audience likes this i know they don't
like that and of course you're speaking
in generalities but
you do genuinely end up getting to know
your audience
and what they can do for you is
amazing i mean i people say like oh it's
amazing daniel interviewed brandon
sanderson
no my audience got me that interview my
audience got me my interview with jo
abercrombie
those people don't care about me they
care about my platform and my audience
and what they've been shown to do um so
when i see you know
other authors tweeting out like oh
daniel boosted my sales i didn't do
anything
my audience did right um so that's
that's something i
i fully believe in and i'm grateful for
them every day i'm occasionally not
grateful when they
try to like find my information but you
know that's
those are the those are the those are
the members we try to cut out those are
the stray people yeah we don't yeah we
don't we don't talk about them
uh i just have a few like uh short
fun random questions if you're down for
answering them
do you know your myers-briggs
personality type
i i just looked it up because you told
me you're gonna ask me that i think it
was like i
n f b does that sound right is that a
thing is it i and i
f b is is it b or p p
it's infp there we go oh no there's a j
in there
because i'm judgmental as hell that's
infj infj there it is
that's that's awesome well cool i think
basically the difference between infp
and infj is that infjs are more
are less indecisive i'm very decisive
i i decide i'm gonna do something i do
it um so
that makes sense that that does make
sense i'm an infp
so i am like the most indecisive person
if you ever need to make up your mind
about something just text me i'll give
you an answer just right away
i'll just immediately decide for you and
respond and be like this what should you
do you heard it folks if you ever
need to figure something out daniel
green
it's worth a shot this is for you jacob
it's exclusive offer
exclusive got it this might be a silly
question but
i am curious as to how you will approach
it who would win in a fight uh khalid
or khalid and storm blessed
clint has a gun and as my recent video
shows
i have a lot of faith in guns uh but
caledon has an insane healing factor
as well as just is so far beyond trained
what she is i mean she's very physically
fit there's a scene where she beats
someone up by just slamming him into a
wall repeatedly klit is
into fitness um she's built
but uh yeah caledon would wipe the floor
with her no question
she might shoot him a couple times so
he'd be upset but that's all she'd
manage
yeah i think she would make him pretty
upset i think you answered um
most of my questions and i really
appreciate you
doing this and talking about the book
this is was
an awesome experience so thank you so
much thank you you're a great
interviewer and if you guys have not
subscribed to man carrying things he's
carrying that subscribe help him carry
more things that's the whole point of
this
thanks man well awesome
thank you so much